sure
so just a few examples are shown here on
the slide so we might encounter
um relational data um such as knowledge
graphs and nlp or
protein-protein interactions in
computational biology which have an
intrinsic hierarchical structure
we also find hierarchies
in form of compositionality
in
video analysis for instance
we also find
metric structures in in applications
either data given
as matrices for instance in fmri or we
might
have a subroutine that is metrics valued
such as a matrix completion task
in recommender systems
so in all of these
systems we have some geometric structure
that we could potentially make
use of
and um the the first step in in
utilizing that geometric structure would
be to think about what is the the right
geometric space to represent our data
and or to rephrase
our machine learning problem
so that's a representation learning
question and then very closely related
to that is the question of generalizing
those classical euclidean algorithms to
romanian manifolds and so that we have
the same methods and algorithms in the
on the romanian manifolds available that
we have in euclidean spaces preferably
so that they are
scalable so that we have hope of
applying them in practice and that we
have the same theoretical guarantees or
or comparable theoretical
guarantees that we have in the euclidean
spaces
and in the rest of the talk i just want
to give um two examples of research
directions in that context um the first
one uh representing hierarchical data so
on this very first slide we saw some
examples of where we find hierarchical
data in in applications and hierarchical
structure means that our data looks
tree-like or can be represented like a
as a tree
and it is a well-known mathematical fact
the trees
embed very well into low dimensional
hyperbolic space that has to do with
volume growth rates which are
in both tree spaces and also in
hyperbolic space exponential whereas in
euclidean spaces volumes of this only
polynomial so in order to
represent faithfully the metric
information in a in a large
tree we would need a very high embedding
dimension in euclidean space but in
hyperbolic spaces only
a low dimensional
space and that fact we can
utilize in
in machine learning
so there's been a lot of recent work in
this area both on representation
learning aspects so understanding for a
given data set when a hyperbolic space
is useful so
understanding representation trade-offs
between different
geometric spaces and then once we have
settled on on the space that we want to
work with how can we efficiently
compute such representations
and then
after dealing with the representation
aspects also downstream machine learning
uh so now that we have a representation
in hyperbolic space um how can we extend
classical euclidean algorithms to these
settings
and that started with um empirical work
on extending classical algorithms like
support vector machines or craft neural
networks to hyperbolic spaces and then
more recently also work on
the theoretical analysis of these
algorithms and recovering um
complexity guarantees for instance
so to give one example of um
uh an algorithm where we have a
algorithm for both uh the euclidean case
and the hyperbolic case so if we look at
a very very basic problem of binary
classification and we assume our data is
separable and we want to learn a
separating hyperplane
to perform a classification then as you
all know in euclidean case we can use
the perceptron algorithm
if our data lies on a on a hyperbolic
manifold so in the
figure here um it's the lawrence model
one from parametrization of hyperbolic
space so we have data points on that
manifold
and then the equivalent problem would be
to learn a euclidean hyperplane here
shown in red
which
intersects our manifold and then the
intersection of the euclidean hyperplane
and the manifold is our precision
boundary
and that would give us a
and
hyperbolic analog of the perceptron
mechanism
and then we can come up with an
algorithm for training such a perceptron
algorithm and also
recover simple complexity guarantees for
instance and then starting from this
very basic algorithm we can extend this
to consider more complex tasks like
maybe learning a much much classifier or
really robust classifiers
nice effects from the geometric
alignment we can actually also observe
in instructors so there's
numerical results for for that as well
and just to mention a second
direction
optimization on metrics manifolds so as
i
initially showed some examples we often
find metrics valued subroutines in
machine learning so we have to optimize
over
a class of matrices under a certain
constraint so if we use euclidean
methods
we can perform a constrained
optimization task in in euclidean spaces
for instance constrained quickly
positive definiteness
and we can also view the problem we
formulate the problem on every money
manifold
in the case of positive definiteness we
can reformulate the problem on the
manifold of positive definite matrices
and then use free money and
unconstrained optimization
to solve an equivalent problem
and examples of such subroutines have
that have been studied in in the
euclidean and romanian setting
there are many many
examples
just a few are here on this slide so for
instance averaging gaussians
metrics completion uh synchronization of
data matrices those are all and problems
where romanian methods have been studied
a particularly
interesting feature of this switch to
the romanian setting is geodesic
convexity
so sometimes we have problems that are
in the euclidean setting
non-convex but that fulfill a weaker
notion of convexity on the respective
manifold so by switching the geometric
lens we gain
convexity and gain access to using tools
from convex optimization
on the on the manifold
my own work in this area has mostly
focused on constraint optimization
and so
where
we just look at this this very basic
formulation so we want to minimize the
function defined on every monument
manifold and we not only want to find
a minimum but we want to find the
minimum that that lies in a certain
compact uh geodesically convex subset of
the manifold
um and in prior work and remanual
optimization has mostly focused on an
unconstrained problem um constraint
problems
so so we were specifically focusing on
this additional difficulty of handling
constraints
and for that we looked into a romanian
version of the framework algorithm which
is a very popular algorithm for
constraint optimization in the euclidean
setting
in euclidean spaces that's been already
studied since the 1950s so very well
known
and established algorithm
in the interest of time i probably
can't say so much about the actual
extension of the algorithm but um let me
say that one can define a romanian
frankfurt algorithm that recovers
most of the the euclidean guarantees so
for for instance that guarantees a
sublinear convergence um to the to the
global optimum in the geodesically
convex case
um and just one note on this extension
of euclidean algorithms through romanian
algorithms it sometimes may seem as
um we're just switching out euclidean
tools for three million tools and then
most of the the proof ideas and
techniques goes through
unfortunately that's that's not always
the case so we often face um additional
difficulties and obstacles in the
romanian setting in this case here
the key difficulty lies in solving
the linear oracle which if you know the
euclidean frank wolfe it's like a
key subroutine in the algorithm and
that's in the euclidean setting a very
simple convex optimization problem but
in the remaining setting much much
harder to solve and requires additional
work to find efficient ways of solving
that
just a
non-geometry related side note i'm also
really interested in
control with with learning problems so
where we learn to
learn a control strategy in a setting
where we have very little time and very
little data so if anyone um also works
in that area i would like to chat about
that
[Music]
yeah yeah so
um for instance on positive definite uh
literacies and internal constraints
and you could also just numerically
solve an approximation and then if it's
like a reasonably good minimizer um you
can still recover something in your
convention
yeah so
there are um cases where this is
great
thank you